hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut ja
Leute was geht neue Kulisse wir haben
eine neue Kulisse und das ist unfassbar
geil für mich geht ein kleiner Traum in
Erfüllung weil man muss einfach sagen
ich habe schon so lange gedacht TK du
brauchst einfach mal ein eigenes Lager
durch mein Hobby verwirklichen kann also
irgendwo ist es halt Nachrichten von
Hobby aber so leute tut mir leid
irgendwie hat der Ton mies
reingeschissen das hatte ich noch nie
mit diesem Mikrofon ich weiß nicht woran
es lag ich habe auf jeden Fall jetzt ein
richtig nices Lager mit ziemlich viel
Platz kurze roomtour ich hoffe ihr
interessiert euch dafür falls nicht es
gibt einfach die haben wir einmal das
Tor und hier kommt man halt rein so
sieht das dann aus Kamera Setup gerade
aufgebaut aber das Problem ist besser
alles hier das muss alles noch weg und
wartet mal wer dafür zuständig ist genau
ich natürlich hier hinter ganz viel rein
Gläser ich habe gar keine Ahnung wie ich
das Loswerden soll ja Weingläser mehr
Weingläser noch mehr Weingläser Teller
Lampen Weihnachtsdeko ich habe das ganze
halt so vom Vormittag übernommen und der
meinte sie zu irgendwie muss es
loswerden du kannst den ganzen Platz du
kannst dich hier frei ausleben das ist
echt cool und ich starte logischerweise
erstmal nur mit dieser Fläche weil mehr
brauche ich nicht ich war letzte Woche
noch unterwegs und ich habe meinen Papa
gebeten dass er hier aufmacht damit die
Retouren reinkommen können und die haben
die einfach mal mitten in den Raum
gestellt das lernt man doch genau und
dann kommen wir hier
es werde nicht also das hier sind
sicherlich auch noch mal boah ich würde
mal schätzen so ca 60 Quadratmeter
wirklich alles leider vollgestellt mit
irgendwelchen Sachen Tische Stühle ich
habe ganz viele Gläser wie z.B diese
hier von Krombacher also wenn irgendwer
von euch was davon haben will schreibt
mir bei insta das wird aber auf jeden
Fall Spaß machen ich freue mich drauf
und wir schauen mal wie sich das Ganze
hier so entwickelt dann habe ich jetzt
aber auf jeden Fall Bock diese beiden
heißen Retouren Paletten auszupacken
endlich mal wieder Retouren wir haben
zwei Stück ich habe die für 1500 € knapp
brutto gekauft also schon einiges und
ich weiß nicht genau was drauf ist also
ich wollte mich überraschen lassen und
das sind jetzt so die anfangs die
anfangs Retouren für mein neues Lager
nice ich habe dann allerdings weil ich
dachte das ist cool doch noch mal
nachgefragt und gefragt was da so drauf
ist woher das kommt das meiste Zeug auf
den Paletten kommt von netto und auch
ein bisschen was von Aldi und der Rest
ist halt keine Ahnung von Amazon und so
wollte ich euch nur eben mal mitteilen
und ähm ja ich bin hier gerade in meinem
neuen Büro auch schon deswegen wundert
euch nicht alles ein bisschen größer
jetzt hier geil ich würde sagen ich
starte logischerweise mal mit der
vorderen
junge ich hatte noch mehrere Palette die
so krank eingepackt ist
1 2 3 4 was ist denn das BVB
heißluftfritteuse digital ey davon
behalte ich ein muss ich eine behalten
aber die scheinen auf jeden Fall
neuwertig zu sein Clean Maxx Hemden
blusenblüher die kenne ich davon habe
ich schon mal welche ähm ja auch nicht
verkehrt sondern wo venta silence ach so
Bügeleisen das da unten ist auf jeden
Fall noch so ein Recycling einmal von
Aldi aber wir kommen jetzt erstmal zum
Sponsor vom heutigen Video Leute bevor
wir weitermachen würde ich euch gerne
den Sponser des heutigen Videos
vorstellen der mir hätte nicht passender
kommen können das Problem ist nämlich
gerade noch ich habe zwar ein super
Lagerraum bzw fast zwei superlager Räume
wenn ich hier aufnehmen und hier ist es
halt ziemlich dunkel habe ich ein
Problem ich habe nur eine Steckdose die
funktioniert und auf der anderen Seite
hier zum Beispiel gar keine und da kommt
jetzt ecoflor ins Spiel
freundlicherweise zwei unterschiedliche
Power Station zur Verfügung gestellt wir
starten einfach mal mit der Delta River
2 die jetzt auch gerade schon hier in
Funktion ist und zwar für meine Lampe da
unten auch gerade schon beim Öffnen hat
die hier fleißig ihren Job verbracht das
ist so ein ganz kleines gedreht ist
wirklich nicht schwer und die haben wir
eine Steckdose bei zwei USB-Anschlüsse
ein usb-c-anschluss wir haben jetzt noch
28%, also die halten echt ewig und das
ist nur das kleine Gerät von ecoflaut
das coole ist die River 2 Powerstation
könnt ihr nur einer Stunde an einer
Steckdose zu 100% vollladen die Victor
dreieinhalb Kilogramm ist also ziemlich
einfach zu transportieren und deckt mit
300 Watt eigentlich die wichtigsten
eurer Geräte ab für die unter euch die
noch mehr und noch länger brauchen
gibt's natürlich noch den Porsche unter
den Eco flow-geräten denn hier haben wir
ich hebt mal wieder hoch habe ich gerade
schon gemacht den Eco Flo Delta das Teil
ist wirklich brachial stark ihr könnt
hier sehen wir haben wieder zwei USB
Anschlüsse wir haben zwei fast charge
USB Anschlüsse zwei USB-Anschlüsse also
wenn ihr mit euren Freunden auf dem
Festival oder einfach so Probleme habt
wie ich hier dann kommt das genau
richtig und wir haben vor allem hier
hinten vier Steckdosen ja also damit
kann man quasi ein ganzes Festival
betreiben oder halt eine Retouren
Lagerhalle von mir die Delta
Powerstation 2 bis dreimal so schnell
wie die meisten anderen tragbaren Power
Station auf dem Markt ihr bekommt sie
nur eine Stunde zu 80% voll geladen und
sie kann Geräte mit bis zu 1.800 Watt
betreiben mein Handy hatte auch nur noch
3% oder so ich habe das mal hier ans
fast Charlie angeschlossen entspannt und
wer das nicht schon genug habe ich zu
Hause auch noch die neue Solarstation
von eco Flow die ich jetzt nicht mit
Tieren genommen habe einfach weil ich
gerade keine Verwendung dafür habe aber
die packen wir jetzt auch noch mal
zusammen aus und schauen uns die an und
natürlich kann man die Geräte auch
miteinander kombinieren super und
vielleicht hier noch im Vergleich also
das River 2 Gerät ist wirklich deutlich
leichter und für den Auto
Normalverbraucher wie mich z.B auch
reicht so ein Ding völlig ne so Leute
hier haben wir noch das Eco Flow
Solarpanel
[Musik]
sieht einfach aus wie vom Haus da ne ich
habe das jetzt nicht mit in mein Lager
genommen weil das hätte mir jetzt nicht
viel gebracht das ist schon ultra dunkel
draußen und heute war das Wetter
miserabel aber man könnte das z.B mit
dem River 2 oder dem Delta connecten und
so dann einfach mit Solarenergie Laden
ich werde das bei Gelegenheit und auch
wenn dann mal wieder die Sonne scheint
mal auf meinem Balkon installieren und
euch dann mal in einer Instagram Story
zeigen wie das so aussieht vor allem in
der jetzigen Zeit wo Strom und
Heizkosten enorm gestiegen sind ist so
ein Ding sicher nicht verkehrt und damit
zurück ins Studio also Leute Check den
ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung ab
schaut euch Eco floor an ich bin ganz
schön außer Atem aber wir machen jetzt
weiter mit den returen ich würde einfach
mal sagen wir machen die erste Palette
hier jetzt im Schnelldurchlauf auf ach
so und was natürlich ganz wichtig ist
der Wert muss wieder eingeblendet werden
aber ich werde die Sachen ihr bekommt
auf jeden Fall am Ende einen uferpel
Gesamtwert also ich werde jetzt nicht
alles einzeln einblenden diese Recycling
einmal gab es ja bei Aldi für etwas mehr
als 100 € und wenn man jetzt schon mal
dabei sind BVB heißt Luft Friteuse oh
das ist nicht so gut für mich die ist
gerade im BVB Shop von 70 € auf 48,99 re
aber kommen die einen hier können wir
aufmachen weil Spielverein Boros für
folgende egal wohin es geht auch in
schlechten Zeiten werden wir die stets
begleiten Borussia wir sind immer für
dich da und man muss ja auch sagen ich
glaube heißluftfritteusen sind aktuell
sehr gefragt ist übrigens für alle die
es wissen wollen ich werde halt wirklich
viele Retouren bestellen deswegen einmal
pro Woche live Shopping Event geben auf
Instagram wo die Sachen zu wirklich
guten günstigen Preisen bekommen könnt
deswegen checkt auf jeden Fall mein
Instagram ab einmal Alex wie da gibt's
die Livestreams und folgt auch auf jeden
Fall Alex wie Shopping weil da wird die
ganze Kommunikation drüber laufen also
super wichtig beides und ähm ja der
nächste Termin findet am Sonntag um 15
Uhr statt nächsten Sonntag schaltet
eigentlich freue mich weiter geht's
heißt du Friteuse Nummer 2 Nummer 3
eigentlich bräuchte ich auch noch so ein
hydraulikgerät
kann dann könnte ich die Palette
wenigstens auch mal für euch drehen weil
gerade obwohl
bitte nicht Unfall
und die Nummer vier hier vierte
heißluftfritteuse ich frage mich wieso
oder so viele heißluftfritteusen drauf
sind von Dortmund die müssen sich doch
verkaufen machen wir weiter was sind das
für ein Schrott slimax Comfort Jeans
sowas hatte ich auch schon mal früher TV
Werbung ja ja das waren mal glaube ich
in so einem netto Paket hatte ich das
alles drin dann haben wir hier noch
Jeans Leggings na ja aber man muss sagen
die Verpackung sieht schon echt toll aus
ganz tolle Verpackung noch mal noch mal
noch mal Alter da kommen diese
Verpackung ist schon auf
du scheiße ey krass das ist wir guck mal
das ist eine aufgemalte Jeans ach und
hinten hier hinten sind Taschen Alter
Outdoor Messer noch mal Outdoor Messer
noch ein Auto Messer sogar TÜV geprüfte
Outdoor Messer oh das ist gerade auch
wegen seven vs white wahrscheinlich äh
gut gefragt ne okay tannenbaumständer
auch nicht schlecht und ich glaube falls
ich es richtig gesehen habe sind das da
oben zwei kunsthandbäume und das hier
müsste jetzt Tannenbaum Nummer eins sein
da steht sogar wer das bestellt hat
Christine okay und hier haben wir noch
einen zweiten davon ich würde sagen wir
müssen meinen aufmachen ich hoffe es ist
eine gute Marke weil das ja geil und wir
haben ja gerade auch Weihnachten also
zumindest fast halt vielen Dank für Ihre
Entscheidung von Weihnachtsbäume ich bau
dir doch jetzt nicht zusammen oder hä
ich dachte die Dinger sind teuer der
kostet ja nur 30 €, aber man muss auch
sagen der fühlt sich jetzt zur
qualitativ nicht gut an naja gut kann
man nichts machen kann ich schauen mal
kurz vorsichtig hier oben rein schaut
mal hier der ist sogar weiß angemalt
aber das wird jetzt auch kein Burner
Modell sein dafür haben wir noch acht
weitere heißluftfritteusen ach das hier
sind sogar anderes
Friteuse eigentlich war das ja noch
heißluftfritteusenpalette ich bin mal
gespannt ob wir eine Sache finden für
über 200 Euro weil eigentlich muss das
schon drin sein ich habe gerade schon
mal weiter gemacht mit so einem Gavia
Deko Säule mit pflanzenschale ja da
waren noch so komische Pflanzenschalen
drauf nichts Besonderes die ja keine
Ahnung habe ich noch nie gesehen vorher
ich mache das jetzt mal hier im
Schnelldurchlauf ebenso genau die gibt's
in verschiedenen Größen diese LED Deko
Pflanzen das ist jetzt 89 cm die anderen
waren glaube ich 59 cm was habe ich mir
hier wieder angetan aber egal es ist
eigentlich ja auch also ich will das ja
und dann hatten wir noch ganz viele
Kleinteile irgendwelche Lockenstäbe für
Damen okay und hier habe ich jetzt aber
gesehen wir haben hier eine Doppelkammer
Friteuse von Max me und die kostet neue
150 € bis jetzt das teuerste dafür haben
wir ja auch 20 heißluftfritteusen hier
sind noch kleinere Gadgets wie Kopfhörer
eine Überwachungskamera und
Fieberthermometer da sind halt super
viele von diesen Max die Sachen drauf
elektrische Edelstahl Armatur hier haben
wir noch ein paar Staubsauger nackten
Massagegerät gleich zweimal eins und
zwei ja die Dinger kosten auch so 45
design for Life oh das ist ein Design
Dingen das ist so ein Designer teelampe
kostet auch 100 € bei Amazon und dann
haben wir jetzt zu guter Letzt die Zeit
Kontaktgrill natürlich wer hat das
gedacht ebenfalls von Max me ja und das
war's dann auch leider schon wir hatten
noch ganz viele Kleinteile die irgendwie
runtergefallen sind Überwachungskameras
Pipapo alles mögliche also ja da ist
schon auf jeden Fall einiges an Wert
drauf gewesen ich brennt euch hier mal
ein Safe über 2500 € 3000 € nicht ganz
aber halt auch nur der UVP werden das
muss man ganz klar sagen und jetzt
machen wir weiter mit der nächsten
Palette ich bin gespannt jetzt ist sie
dran ich zeige euch mal so sieht das
jetzt gerade hier aus ich warte mal
aufgereiht eigentlich ganz funny also
ich glaube so viele Sachen hatte ich
selten auf einmal ich habe ja auch in
meinem Büro ich ziehe jetzt übrigens
noch einen größeres auch nicht so viel
Platz gehabt aber in den brauche ich
jetzt auch nicht mehr also ich habe
jetzt zwar trotzdem mehr Platz aber für
meine Retouren brauche ich den Platz
nicht mehr weil dann habe ich hier und
das ist ja auch einfach geiler so jetzt
schauen wir mal was haben wir denn hier
wenn es geht nicht umfallen
alter das ist so wie KitchenAid
wahrscheinlich muss ich mir mal genauer
anschauen okay erstmal jetzt das oben
alles runter nehmen weil sonst habe ich
gleich ein Problem ein großes Problem
nicht runterfallen nicht runterfallen
okay Alex konzentriere Dich jetzt mal
jetzt glaube ich nicht so schlau
[Musik]
so zack zack ah Spielzeuge Playmobil
Lego Alter okay verstehe ist das denn
und eigentlich könnte ich das jetzt auch
abnehmen komm zack geil dicker warum ist
denn da jetzt so ein riesen Karton drum
gewesen wir haben hier ich seh schon
Nerf Pistolen LEGO Friends ein rocking
Schaukelpferd okay ach komm wir gehen
mal eben rum Babystuhl Kinderschaukel
und Galileo und Globus guck mal
ach das ist so eine Küche zwei Küchen so
Kinderküchen okay Leute muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen ist jetzt denke ich nicht
so krass interessant fürs Youtube Video
deswegen machen wir jetzt im Livestream
auf für alle die die Kinder haben wird
es dann sicherlich ganz cool ich habe
noch kein Kind da bin ich aktueller noch
ganz froh drum na ja ich hoffe trotzdem
das Retouren Paletten Video hat euch mal
wieder gefallen und ich kann euch auch
sagen in Zukunft gibt es wieder coole
Parts also mit interessanten Sachen bin
jetzt diese Woche noch unterwegs in
Leipzig bei einem Bekannten der hat auch
super viel und ja das schauen wir uns
das ganze auch mal an weil wir hatten
jetzt auch länger keine Retouren Videos
auf dem Kanal leute danke fürs zuschauen
abonniert den Kanal super gerne Däumchen
nach oben wäre super checkt unbedingt
die Produkte von Eko Flop gerade in der
jetzigen Zeit super wichtig und die
Sachen sind echt top alles natürlich wie
schon gesagt in der Videobeschreibung
verlinkt und Leute wir sehen uns in 23
Tagen wieder Videos kommen jetzt
eigentlich immer Mittwochs und Sonntag
haut rein Leute ciao